oh man come on new lamp just dropped
what is this yo this is gonna be the
product that's linked on every viral
tweet for the rest of the year right
here
you like this tweet buy this buy this
light for your home oh you move the
foreskin down yeah and it turns on yeah
who thought this was a good idea is that
actually real
what is the point of this you know to
put it in your sex room like is it
supposed to be a sexual thing or is it
supposed to be like oh it is it's called
a boner lamp Okay well then it's genius
damn bro
capitalism at its finest yeah dumbest
[ __ ] product ever boner lamp love it
I actually love it actually big fan uh
you know what I'm gonna order a ton now
was that a boner lamp Master Class yeah
you too can make your own boner life and
it's just instructions on how to buy one
from their website yeah what is that
butterfly flap switch what is that
supposed to be a flap switch for what oh
it's because they circumcise a butterfly
and then they stretch the skin out into
a oh I see yeah yeah it doesn't make
that alcohol that videos I feel like
that video turning on the lamp wasn't
done
like turning on the lamp and then the
hand goes out and then like an ass yeah
just that's fully what I was expecting
that's how you that's how you're
supposed to turn it on I wanted to make
some stupid ass joke on this tweet where
it's like oh your ass cheeks are gonna
be glowing after this [ __ ] dude just
looking like a [ __ ] like some nuclear
just glowing orb and like yeah yeah like
taking that picture of agent Smith
before he blows up it's like me after
putting my ass on my boner lamp
pull that up agent Smith about to
explode Matrix one
bro imagine some interior designer been
like I found these amazing sconces
but you're gonna love these but they
don't view them as sexual yeah exactly
this is clearly it's like you pull the
foreskin down no no no no no no no no no
no no no
you dude it's the right it's right yeah
yes was the last time you watched this
movie oh I don't know I've never seen it
actually I'm kidding
I would jump across this
and that's the first movie we're gonna
go see look look look look look yeah
yeah wait for it right there
right there and right there yeah there
it is
crazy
what is in here that's your crack he
just cracks that down he just sat down
on the boner lamp
your ass is so pissed dude yeah
[ __ ] glowing ass crack what are you
doing in here I gotta tweet that on the
break
are you saying his ass is glowing or
saying his it's coming up all the way
through his body no no his ass like no I
think he's sitting on it and then the
light is peeking through his mouth yes
yeah like what's her face from The Fifth
Element yeah
[Laughter]
no
Fifth Element no
no I have seen the first half of Elvis
though
and boy was that have you you guys
haven't seen that I have and in theaters
and I think it's pretty good it's good I
have not seen it the whole movie feels
like a like a trailer so it's like it's
very exciting yeah yeah yeah the way
that yeah what's his name
Andrew Garfield now
not uh the guy who wrote and directed it
boss Lerman
he's wild everybody
has something to tell you guys one more
time
moment House show happening in three
weeks September 8th 5 p.m Pacific get a
ticket it's gonna be a banger it's gonna
be a bang-a-linger moment dot Co slash
tiny meat gang and that's moments.co
yeah slash tiny meat gang go buy a
ticket it's gonna be a banger we'll see
you there